so I think the things we have to do is
always debate everything always debate
everything become far less headline
readers Facebook had some reporting
errors on things that we never even
reported against cuz they didn't really
matter right so like but everybody hears
that or vice versa whatever the
headlines are so I think attention is
what you need to trade on here's another
one
I believe that buying I am a massive
anti programmatic banner and pre-roll
digital ad buyer I am at the highest
levels and and I just don't think it's a
good idea to be on weekly savings org
bottom left-hand corner banner ad when
the justification is the CPM cost nobody
saw it so I think we have you know if
you and I were doing this chat right now
and there was nobody in here it wouldn't
matter what the creative is and so first
we have to nail that down and then we
have to nail down the creative and I
think using the piggyback off the
election different people want to hear
different things and thank you you know
for whatever you think of it for me
thankfully if nothing you know at the
most micro levels cuz they're much
bigger macro issues with politics if
nothing else people are now debating
like oh right you can't give people the
same message the days of marketing of
Chase it's for all of you looked like
it's over like Vennela marketing is dead
because we had to vanilla market for 50
years because they were blunt objects
she ran a commercial to everybody but it
meant nothing
because when you try to mean something
to everybody in one fell swoop you mean
nothing to anybody
[Music]